it's called multiple sclerosis because
multiple areas of the brain or spinal
cord are attacked and depending on where
the attack occurs you have different
symptoms the drug sells four billion
dollars a year sales worldwide a year's
supply of it costs about twenty-five
thousand dollars so there's
approximately twenty to twenty-five
percent of the individuals taking this
drug who may not benefit at all we
didn't have a good rationale for
deciding what first-line drug to use and
we didn't know why they might not be
responding and why some people were good
responders we have different types of
white blood cells that cause
inflammation and just for the sake of
the discussion one of those types of
white blood cells is called th1 and the
other type that immunologists are very
interested in is called th17 to our
surprise and amazement it made the th17
form of eae worse the animals instead of
becoming able to walk again developed
worst paralysis whereas the animals that
were genetically identical but induced
with the th1 lymphocytes got better in a
sense they were throwing away their
crutches and and walking normally
and lo and behold if you're high in
il-17 you will not respond to beta
interferon so the results in man were
entirely congruent with the results that
we saw in the mouse that was really
quite exciting if it holds up there will
be a predictive test that will tell a
person whether or not they should take
beta interferon in the first place or
perhaps use that other drug co pacsun
and then there's several new drugs that
are about to be approved so one will
have choices that you can make and
hopefully the choices now will be guided
by at least four beta interferon a
predictive test
you